[Música]
desde la bienvenida a este episodio de
boleto de vuelta que hoy nos lleva de
nuevo a la histórica catedral de notre
damme en parís que sigue siendo
reconstruida tras un voraz incendio en
2019 en la noche del 15 al 16 de abril
el mundo miraba desconcertado en lo que
sucedía en otra edad el certidumbre
crecía sobre la suerte de la estructura
del edificio luego llegó el tiempo de
las promesas el de la reconstrucción y
los juegos olímpicos de parís 2024 todo
un desafío teniendo en cuenta la
pandemia del cob y 19 y las difíciles
condiciones de trabajo especialmente por
el polvo de plomo muy tóxico emanado por
el fuego del techo un boleto de vuelta
nos comprometimos a seguir esta
reconstrucción para hacer un completo
balance en la edición de nuestro
programa de 2021 visitamos el lugar
conocimos al arquitecto de los
monumentos históricos a los habitantes
del barrio a los carpinteros que
aseguraron las bóvedas centenarias a los
restauradores de las pinturas el general
yo yo la encargado de la restauración en
a pesar de todas las dificultades se
mostró optimista un año después estamos
a la mitad del cronograma plan
pero la fase de restauración real aún no
ha comenzado atención aumenta sigue
siendo posible una reapertura de las
puertas de novedad para 2024 en
cualquier caso muchos trabajan
contrareloj para lograr este objetivo
boleto de vuelta al sitio de
reconstrucción de nuestra edad segundo
episodio
antiguos árboles gigantes que han
crecido en estos bosques durante cientos
de años milímetro a milímetro en 2021
estos robles se encontraban en el ocaso
de su vida pero con sus 40 metros de
altura al caer al suelo
[Música]
aunque parezca extraño tendrán una
segunda vida
porque hacen parte de los 2000 robles
necesarios para la reconstrucción de
notredame cuya estructura conocida como
el bosque se esfumó en el incendio del
15 de abril de 2019
[Música]
mira es perfecto no tiene ni siquiera un
pequeño nudo nada qué bueno viste el
crecimiento y los anillos este creció
lentamente tiene un muy buen gran clair
quiñones y aymerich albert trabajan en
la oficina nacional de bosques tuvieron
que escoger cuidadosamente cada árbol
que debía ser talado se puede ver bien
la forma de la viga con una ruptura en
la mitad
era necesario que el árbol tuviera esa
curvatura de manera natural para que sea
lo más sólido posible que no se deforme
con el tiempo y este árbol responde
perfectamente a lo que nos habían pedido
el organismo público y los arquitectos
este roble hace parte de los ocho
privilegiados que conformarán la base de
la aguja
se trata de la estructura de madera que
sostiene esta obra maestra y que pronto
será reconstruida de manera idéntica a
la que se inauguró en el siglo 19
desaparecida en la noche del incendio
el árbol que acabamos de talar tiene una
calidad excepcional y es el más hermoso
de los otros tiene más de 3 metros de
calidad que es la calidad perfecta así
que resulta muy emocionante porque es un
trabajo excepcional de varias
generaciones de guardabosques y ahora
podemos cosechar pero antes de terminar
en la cima de notre-dame estos árboles
tienen todavía un largo camino por
delante para la siguiente etapa llegamos
nueve meses después a mayer al alba el
aserradero de los gigantes cuyo nombre
nunca ha sido más adecuado se prepara
para cortar estos mastodontes
[Música]
hace poco me cae el cambio de profesión
para convertirse en carpintero abrió su
aserradero en 2020
[Música]
pero esta joven empresa artesanal no fue
escogida por azar monte el aserradero
para fabricar barcos con base de madera
utilizábamos grandes largueros para
hacer mástiles o quillas de barcos y de
repente en el 2020 me llamaron para
saber si quería cortar los grandes
largueros de la catedral de notre-dame
los robles que llegan del bosque de
verse son gigantescos entonces tuvimos
que adaptarnos a eso una vez cortado el
leño mide entre 20 y 25 metros hay
varios de diferentes tamaños y yo soy el
único que puede cortar piezas tan largas
aún así para llevar a cabo este trabajo
fuera de lo común fue necesario agrandar
el aserradero y ajustar los equipos son
piezas bastante impresionantes y sobre
todo masivas pesa unas 15 toneladas
pienso que tengo la suerte de poder
hacer este trabajo creo que más de uno
quisiera haber estado en mi lugar pero
me tocó a mí así que soy consciente de
la suerte que tengo de poder tocar estos
árboles que tienen 250 años y que
vivirán durante muchos años más en una
catedral
llegó la hora de cortar el primer roble
el que nació antes de la revolución
francesa pero la operación no se hace
sin la oficina nacional de bosques
nos encontramos con claire quiñones que
contribuyó a escoger estos robles
nos explica que estos árboles no fueron
sacrificados por no traerán de parís no
se puede hacer una gestión sostenible si
no se renueva el bosque y en algún
momento dado estos venerables ancianos
estos árboles que están aquí necesitan
tener hijos y reproducirse al cabo de
200 años el árbol alcanza su madurez así
que lo cosechamos y debajo hay toda una
generación de pequeños árboles que
crecerán y dentro de 200 años esto es lo
maravilloso y lo mágico de la gestión
sostenible dentro de 200 años habrá
nuevos árboles como este y un evento
excepcional como éste merece una
audiencia excepcional unos 40 medios de
comunicación y el jefe de las obras de
notredame en persona el general giorgi
land
está impresionado por la participación
de los artesanos que han venido desde
todas partes de francia
el eco que esta obra ha tenido en el
país está despertando vocaciones es
bastante espectacular esto muestra lo
ejemplar y emblemática que es notredame
además quedará un legado de esta obra
pero antes de un eventual legado es
necesario avanzar porque quedan dos años
para la reapertura prevista estos robles
deberán secarse ser ensamblados por
carpinteros y sólo hasta 2023 se
montarán en la catedral
[Música]
en parís el tiempo está contado un
enemigo casi invisible encontró refugio
en las alturas de la catedral la humedad
causada por el agua de los bomberos y
luego por la intemperie hizo que las
sales migrarán hasta la superficie de
las piedras que amenazan con
desmoronarse
giuseppina llena en cabeza una obra
crucial la desalinización los equipos 6
mujeres y 12 hombres extienden una
especie de compresas sobre cada
centímetro cuadrado de las bóvedas de la
catedral
la energía
es caulín y está es arcilla y arena muy
pura y lo mezclamos con agua
desmineralizada
un agua que no tiene sal
hacemos una mezcla que ya está
estabilizada y después la aplicamos con
ayuda de esta máquina
luego la analizamos para obtener un
grosor de 0,5 milímetros
haz los últimos y luego al ib-salut
esta capa es llamada sacrificial porque
será retirada en unos meses tiempo
suficiente para verificar que la sal ha
desaparecido y que ya no es una amenaza
para la estructura un trabajo titánico
es que hay varias fases en la
restauración se ve un andamio y de un
momento a otro es magnífico
pero las personas no saben que todo está
hecho a mano claro tenemos máquinas que
pueden ayudar pero después siempre en
manos humanas que hacen el trabajo es un
trabajo muy físico pero muy
satisfactorio
para esta italiana que desde hace 20
años se dedica a este tipo de
restauración es la obra de nuestra edad
no tiene equivalentes en el mundo
portu
pero hoy en día cuando dice es natural
en todas partes del mundo la gente la
conoce
no todas más ha sido glorificado en los
libros en comedias musicales no jodamos
mucho más que una catedral
nos dolió el alma cuando vimos el
incendio fue terrible así que estoy muy
contenta de estar aquí
a unos metros de la obra de llena el
aparador del gran órgano que se salvó de
las llamas no se ha movido y tampoco sus
gruesos tubos de la fachada pero los
otros 8.000 que lo conformaban al igual
que sus fuelles fueron desmontados uno
por uno y están siendo renovados muy
lejos de parís
[Música]
es en esta pequeña comuna en el sur de
francia donde ahora se encuentra una
parte del instrumento en el taller
manufacturero de grandes órganos
dirigido por salt sang lot desde hace 24
años
[Música]
para nuestra empresa es muy gratificante
participar en la restauración de este
órgano aquí algo de seguro es no te dan
así que no hay duda nos emociona por
supuesto
en este taller se restauran los
diecinueve fuelles del gran órgano es
decir el corazón del instrumento es la
base de madera sobre la que reposarán
sus miles de tubos
él fue y es lo que distribuye el viento
a los tubos cuando el organista toca una
tecla en el teclado agita esta válvula
tira de una válvula en realidad hace que
el viento recorre toda esta pila de
grabados para alimentar una nota del
teclado
por ejemplo tocar a todos los dos de
cada interpretación y luego el organista
escoge entre todos esos dos qué
interpretación quiere tocar está por
ejemplo creo que es la corneta y luego
aquí está la trompeta y así
sucesivamente están todos los
instrumentos musicales
115 registros que conforman el
instrumento musical más grande de
francia una vez desmontado es difícil
imaginarse su tamaño 12 metros de alto
por 12 de largo así que es als nos ayudó
a visualizarlo
aquí hay un fuelle pero en el órgano hay
una gran cantidad alineada igual que por
arriba donde también hay una gran
cantidad sobre todos ellos reposan los
tubos
y el organista en relación con el
aparador porque todo está contenido en
el aparador tiene su consola por fuera
le da la espalda al aparador
y toca frente al coro
los fuelles contaminados por el plomo
durante el incendio primero fueron
descontaminados antes de llegar a este
taller
y aprovechamos que todo se desmontó para
hacer una inspección minuciosa de los
fuelles es decir los probamos los
pusimos ambiente se ponen bajo presión
en las condiciones en la que están
cuando están dentro del instrumento y se
verifican absolutamente todas las notas
para ver si hay préstamos es decir si
hay una nota que suena al lado de la que
se está tocando no se deben escuchar dos
revisamos todo eso vimos que había
algunos pequeños problemas e hicimos
todas las correcciones bueno tener un
oído musical en este caso no es muy
importante
en efecto no suena muy armonioso pero
funciona y eso es lo importante porque
la voz de notredame que se escucha desde
mil 733 debe poder volver a sonar dentro
de un poco más de un año
claro nos alegra escuchar volver a
escuchar todo esto pero bueno deben
darnos un poco de tiempo para hacer el
trabajo eso es
cada fue implica en promedio 250 horas
de trabajo entonces aquí igual que en
las otras obras el tiempo está contado
último regreso a notre damme falta una
etapa importante antes de la
reconstrucción de la estructura en la
limpieza y la descontaminación
durante el incendio cientos de toneladas
de plomo se fundieron y se depositaron
en forma de polvo tóxico por toda la
edificación
sumándose al polvo acumulado desde el
siglo 19
debemos quitar está contaminación en
particular los óxidos de plomo que se
depositaron y que están mezclados con el
polvo inicial para poder trabajar
después en condiciones salubres y
conformes a los objetivos de protección
de los compañeros que trabajarán en la
obra junto con su equipo pascal khune
verifica que los andamios estén ubicados
sin riesgo para los equipos de
descontaminación
aquí todavía hay huecos en el marco
porque aquí estamos a más de 20
centímetros eso no es normal hay que
manejarlo de la mejor manera posible
y montar los andamios casi tocando las
estructuras fue un trabajo muy delicado
porque evidentemente son obstáculos que
hay que rodear y que no se pueden mover
estos andamios gigantes tuvieron que
adaptarse a toda la complejidad de la
catedral rodeando por ejemplo la
ubicación de sus obras de arte
este es un grupo de estatuas muy famoso
de la catedral que se llama el foto de
louis 13 que está instalado en el eje
del coro aquí pueden ver los elementos
de la estatua que han sido restaurados
como este dedo que está roto y fue
reparado o reemplazado tal vez es
posible ver un poco para tener una idea
de la suciedad que puede haber en esta
estatua el resultado del trabajo de
limpieza es impactante ya se pueden
percibir las bóvedas de la catedral tal
como las contemplaron los habitantes del
siglo 19 de un blanco inmaculado
pero a dos años del final de los
trabajos la mayor sorpresa de esta obra
no estaba en el techo del suelo surgió
un descubrimiento excepcional
[Música]
hubo fuego fuerte aquí la aguja cayó
aquí había una montaña de escombros que
fuimos quitando poco a poco y estos
elementos estaban escondidos ahí estos
elementos son fragmentos del antiguo
coro alto de en otra edad del cual sólo
se habían encontrado algunas piezas
conservadas en el museo del look pero
también apareció un sarcófago
antropomorfo en plomo que posiblemente
data del siglo 14
pudimos introducir una cámara
endoscópica en el interior permitió
identificar restos del tejidos pero
también en materias orgánicas como
cabellos y también recién digitales en
particular a la altura de la cabeza de a
pequeñas hojas a primera vista parecería
que es madera de boj pero está por
confirmarse era una práctica reservada a
una herida social no estamos hablando de
embalsamamiento sino de preservación
máxima del cuerpo el hecho de que estos
restos vegetales todavía estén ahí es
signo de una excelente calidad de
conservación de su contenido
pero los trabajos de reconstrucción
deben primar sobre este descubrimiento
excepcional después de haber obtenido
una extensión del plazo los arqueólogos
deberán irse de notredame en el lugar de
su excavación se levantará un andamio de
100 metros de altura necesario para la
reconstrucción de la aguja
llegamos al final de este episodio de
boleto de vuelta a notre damme segunda
entrega recuerde que si quiere ver este
y otros capítulos en español puede
visitar nuestra página web france24
puntocom hasta pronto